- What do you feel like the best lesson,
other than her being so supportive,
I imagine you're like that with your kids
because you were taught
that from a young age,
but what do you think the biggest lesson
you got from her was?
- Oh, believe in yourself.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- 'Cause we grew up in a
really poor neighborhood
with not much.
And you know, there was no
reason for me to believe
that I was gonna be here and make it.
But she always instilled
in me believe in yourself,
you could do whatever you want.
And that, I instill that in
my kids and I believe it.
- That's incredible.
'Cause not all parents do
that, you know what I'm saying?
- [Darius] Definitely not, I know.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- When I was a kid and she instilled in us
that you help people, not
people that are less fortunate.
You help people that need help.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I tell this story about my
brother, I guess I was 10,
probably not 10, I was
probably seven or eight
and my brother was 14 and he went to,
we had this couple that
lived in our neighborhood
and the husband was in the Navy.
And so, he went away on the ship
and the yard was growing up
and my brother went home,
went over and cut her grass,
and she gave him $10.
And he came home bragging
about the $10 he got.
And my mom whooped his butt
and told him, "You take that $10 back down
"and you give it back to her
"because we don't help people for money.
"We help people to help people."
And that was just something.
- Oh, wow.
You got a great mom.
Wow.
Very, very lucky.
Well, we have a little surprise for you
and I was very excited
to be able to do this.
- Do ya?
- Yeah, you don't know.
He really doesn't know about it.
This is not TV, this is real.
For your many, many charitable
efforts over the years
and for helping those who need help,
CMA is actually honoring you
as Humanitarian of the Year.
- Wow.
(audience cheering)
Oh my goodness.
Wow.
- I was so excited.
- That's awesome.
Wow.
(audience cheering)
I really did not know that.
- I know.
I was like, "No, he really doesn't know."
- I did not know that.